thank you  what's going on here how's it going man  how are you what's going on here what's  going on here what's going on here put  that down what's going on here what are  you doing  what are you doing can you not talk to  me just for uh just for the what are you  doing hey don't do that don't do that  again  whoa what hit me go go first go first go  go go go go go go far I'm not gonna go  for it yeah go hit me oh you started oh  I'm starting it yeah  so you know she's not just a guy from  you're actually a Paparazzi guy  nah I can't do it  yeah you know you can do it  yeah cause you're filming yeah but if  that was off I'd be whipping your ass up  and down this tree yeah go